hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the chief executives of facebook and
twitter appearing before the senate
judiciary committee this week
answering questions on everything from
their platform's content moderation
policies
allegations of censorship and their
efforts to limit the spread of election
misinformation
howard kurtz host of media buzz on the
fox news channel
and the media buzz meter podcast shares
his insight
on whether social media companies should
be regulated and how he says news
organizations
should be handling coverage of the trump
campaign's legal challenges
over election results and a number of
states are rolling out
new covet 19 restrictions amid a surge
of u.s cases
ahead of the holidays fox news sunday
host chris wallace discusses the latest
precautions
coronavirus vaccines and how his
personal thanksgiving plans are impacted
plus commentary from fox nation host
tammy bruce
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm harris faulkner i'm greg gutfeld i'm
janis dean
and this is the fox news rundown
friday november 20th 2020 i'm lisa brady
as president trump continues to
challenge the election in court
the media and social media are also
under scrutiny for their handling of the
election
and their coverage of the president so
much of the country was divided over
trump
love him or hate him that it really
drove a lot of media coverage a lot of
ratings and a lot of clicks
i don't think we'll see that in abiding
presidency i'm chris foster
for now at least there appears to be no
plans for the white house to coordinate
with president-elect biden's team on a
coronavirus response and vaccine
distribution
if there is you know is no concession no
transition
uh and and instead of hitting the ground
running on january 20th president-elect
biden
you know hits the ground going from a
standing start
we talked to fox news sunday host chris
wallace and i'm tammy bruce i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
the trump campaign's lawyers are
reiterating claims of election fraud
suggesting a centralized plan by
democrats especially in big cities
to boost the vote count for joe biden
even as election officials
and the federal agency that oversees
elections continue to deny
any compromised votes but in six
battleground
states rudy giuliani said thursday there
are more than enough ballots in question
to affect the outcome we more than
double
the number of votes needed to overturn
the election in terms of provable
illegal ballots he cites sworn
affidavits which he didn't want to show
some from poll workers claiming they
witnessed fraud like
votes being counted more than once and
more votes than registered voters in
some areas
he also chastises the media for
continuing to report
a lack of evidence the censorship that
is going on in this country right now
by big tech and by big media
is almost as dangerous as the election
fraud we're revealing
media and social media treatment of
election issues was also
back in the spotlight on capitol hill
this week was twitter
being a publisher when it censored the
new york post
the answer from twitter ceo jack dorsey
to texas republican senator ted cruz
was no that it wasn't censorship because
they have clear policies on what's
allowed and users agree to follow them
but he also agreed the platform's
handling of a hunter biden story was a
mistake democrats say
not enough is being done to stop
misinformation facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg was asked if he would commit
to removing steve bannon's account
after the former white house strategist
posted that he'd like to see the heads
of dr fauci and the fbi chief
put on pikes having a content violation
does not automatically mean your content
your
your account gets taken down and the
number of strikes varies depending on
the amount
the the type of offense some in congress
are considering a change to strip
the shield social media companies have
from legal liability over what's posted
right now the social media giants
deserve all the criticism they're
getting and more
howard kurtz is host of media buzz on
the fox news channel and the media buzz
meter podcast
i mean obviously when you know jack
dorsey and mark zuckerberg are hauled
before a congressional committee there's
a certain amount of posturing for the
cameras and
it's in their interests of these
lawmakers to try to beat them up for
their own purposes
but look we have seen just in the waning
weeks of the election
twitter go into a censorship mode and a
one-sided censorship motor is simply no
question about it
uh hiding spiking slapping warning
labels on all kinds of tweets from
president trump his campaign and his
allies doing nothing
to the other side so that in itself has
reinforced
uh some long simmering complaints from
conservatives that they believe that
twitter is is biased to the left at the
same time you have
uh democrats during the uh campaign
elizabeth warren when she was running
for president called for breaking up
facebook
and there's constant questions about the
handling of misinformation and
disinformation so
it's a tough time for these companies
and given that
their attempts to clean it up always
seem to be
too little too late uh i think they
deserve a lot of this criticism
is regulation the only way to really
level the playing field if you will on
social media
or is it one of those things where
government involvement
would be a mistake a year ago i would
have said regulation
was should just be completely off the
table because who's going to do the
regulating how do we know that the
government agency
charged with regulating um wouldn't have
its own
uh biases depending on which
administration is in power but now i
think
some change in regulations is inevitable
on twitter and facebook and
the other tech giants basically have
themselves to blame for that even mark
zuckerberg is no longer opposing
uh changes to this section of the law
that provides total immunity
for these companies which you know for a
long time they are
become the most powerful media companies
on earth and yet they assist oh we're
just like the phone company people say
whatever they want yeah we crack down on
hate speech
and bullying but by and large we can't
be held
responsible for people post well it's
about time
given their tremendous influence and
their
their ability to sort of crush a story
that they deemed to be
unsupported or unfair that they took
more responsibility just like the
networks do
just like the newspapers do just like
the magazines do just like major
websites
do for what people post uh and
not just try to hide behind uh this
legal immunity
well there is a lot of control there
over what people
hear and see and ultimately think right
because
sort of the the big three regular
networks if you will
um in their evening newscasts didn't
even include
this senate hearing from wednesday right
well you know the evening newscast as an
arbiter of what's important in the news
i think long since have relinquished
that role they have 22 minutes without
commercials
sometimes those judgments are influenced
by bias and after all we are in the
middle of both
uh a pretty bitter election battle
uh president trump challenging joe
biden's apparent victory in the
presidential race
and a pandemic that is getting worse and
worse and worse i understand that this
is the second hearing
in a few weeks where the tech ceos have
gotten beaten up
um so sure i mean when news
organizations choose to just ignore a
story
it used to be that pretty much it did
not exist
now thanks to places like youtube
snapchat twitter facebook this is the
good side of what they do
everybody can have a voice everybody can
go online spew their opinion share links
and be part of a larger conversation
that's a good thing
you know a handful of media executives
shouldn't control that
but what happens has happened is that
facebook and twitter
in particular and others uh have allowed
us to get out of control
they did a terrible job during the 2016
election they tried better
they tried uh their efforts increased
somewhat during the 2020 election
at least as far as foreign interference
from russia
and countries like that but when it came
to
dealing with political advertising
political partisans
statements that are just factually
unsupported they seem to think well
we'll just
crush what we don't agree with and
and that will be fine and the problem is
it's not fine
we can't have a system where the silicon
valley corporations can override the
judgment for example
of the new york post uh by by refusing
to allow
anybody to share the allegations against
hunter biden that were made by people
associated with the trump campaign now
that new york post story
may have been terrible or it may have
been fine but
the there was an attempt to suppress it
to censor it and ironically
that ended up drawing more attention um
to the story that otherwise would have
gotten then jack dorsey at the hearing
the other day
did apologize for the handling of it and
said they made a mistake and they
changed the policy
what about the media's handling of joe
biden
in general president trump had accused
him of hiding in his basement during the
campaign
he didn't take reporters questions very
often and when he did the media was
accused of giving him
softballs and then since his
projected win as president-elect more
softballs
during the campaign biden had a strategy
and that strategy was
uh spent most of the summer and had his
delaware home
not do many interviews uh let president
trump dominate the media spotlight in a
way that would make the campaign the
election
more of a referendum on him and i guess
you'd have to say that it worked
i constantly complained that uh
journalists usually cry bloody murder if
they don't get access and
and biden gave so little access even to
his own press corps it took so few
questions at sophie national
television interviews uh that i think uh
we we as a profession should have made
more about it now since the election
look i understand a new president-elect
gets a little bit of a honeymoon
at his news conferences so far biden's
been asked what future policies would
you pursue and that's fine
but most of the questions have been
about how
why doesn't president trump concede
don't should you take legal action
isn't this hampering you and just
basically open invitations
for biden to beat up on trump and i
think
the early indications are that once joe
biden becomes president first of all
he's not going to be talking to
reporters five six times a day
uh like president trump does very few
presidents have done anything resembling
that
um but if the if if joe biden continues
to get
questions that are basically polite
deferential
inviting him to attack the opposition a
lot of people out there including the 48
percent of the country
that voted for president trump are going
to conclude that there's a double
standard
that for all of the harshness and
negativity directed at the incumbent
president
which journalists tried to explain by
saying well he does all these outrageous
things and we have to hold them
accountable if they don't
uh apply a similar standard to holding
joe biden accountable
then they're going to i think face a
backlash
from much of the country a lot of the
coverage of
president trump at this point seems
focused
on his refusal to concede instead of the
details of what's happening with his
challenges in court is it is it fair for
networks to be you know dismissive
of one side's arguments well i think
that the president's legal arguments
have gotten a fair amount of coverage
and i think
since he hasn't won any major cases in
any of the contested states and since
he and rudy giuliani have thrown out a
lot of claims that
they have not provided evidence for that
it is fair for the media to be
aggressive and say
uh you know while we certainly think the
president has every right to do this
uh if he doesn't back it up with
evidence and if there are legal setbacks
of which to read many i think it's fair
to to cover that the notion that he
hasn't conceded i mean
it's sort of a very novel news story
i mean if you throw out bush versus gore
in two thousand you know any president
any
presidential candidate who is declared
the winner by the major networks and has
a margin you know
biden basically trump would have to flip
three states in order to overturn
results of this election that's
newsworthy in itself
but it does seem the tone of the way
particularly when blindness questioned
in the tone of many of the reports
that many of the anchors journalists and
commentators as well
are kind of outraged that president
trump is still pursuing this that i
think crosses the line but i do think
it's
it's fair to question does he have
evidence of
widespread fraud and remember it has to
be fraud at a high enough level
to overcome the margins that joe biden
has amassed in states like pennsylvania
and other battleground states
assuming president trump ends up out of
office
how much will the media landscape change
i mean even if he keeps
tweeting well first of all i think
donald trump will get enormous
attention uh over the next four years uh
first he's got the 88 million
twitter followers and you know he it
turned out to be a closer election than
people thought and he whether he starts
a tv network or whatever he does
he will remain a major force in in the
news
but i think we're going to be looking at
a much lower key
presidency again whether the reporters
are tough on joe biden or not
i think biden is kind of signaling to
people a return to a calmer political
environment
one in which he doesn't try to demonize
his opponents when when she doesn't
attack
the media as the enemy of the people one
of which he wants to work with
republicans
whether that happens or not remains to
be seen but there has never quite
been a presidency like donald trump's
and for all the irony here is that for
all the constant negativity and attacks
on this president
uh he was very good for the media's
bottom line new york times washington
post their digital subscription sword
cnn and msnbc while they still trail fox
substantially
uh we're seeing ratings they never
imagined i mean so much of the country
was divided over trump
love him or hate him that it really
drove a lot of media coverage a lot of
ratings and a lot of clicks
i don't think we'll see that in a biden
presidency and i think the country will
have to get used to going back to
a a a world in which every hour
we're not all fixated on what happens in
washington politics
howard kurtz host of media buzz and the
media buzz meter podcast
thank you so much for your time thanks i
appreciate it
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
about 1200 americans a day have died on
average over the last week of
coronavirus and more people than ever
are in the hospital with it
that has new restrictions announced in
several states this week some governors
who resisted them are now changing their
minds
there's a statewide mass mandate in iowa
an expanded one in mississippi
we are taking a county by county
approach that's governor tate reeves
kansas governor laura kelly says in
counties that don't require masks now
we're going to give them a one week to
put together their own
ordinance and starting today no more
indoor dining in minnesota and governor
tim walt says people should
only be socializing with people from
within their own households
it's not easy and it's not fair but it's
a sacrifice that we need to make
if we don't do that and we continue to
spread
we will with absolute certainty put our
hospitals at risk and those that need
the care as well as the care providers
a lot of health care workers are getting
sick themselves others are burned out or
simply overwhelmed
here's the real danger here this isn't
just a matter of statistics
180 000 cases and now we're back to
about 2 000 deaths a day it's the
hospital
system it's the health care system chris
wallace is the host of fox news sunday
i've talked to some really smart people
and not trump doctors not biden doctors
to doctors
who and health officials who say
if this continues on this path by
christmas the healthcare system in this
country is going to be completely
overwhelmed
and you're going to have more you know
and these are
potentially life-threatening cases
although we've gotten better at handling
it
of covid than we have hospital
facilities to handle it and
you know at that point you you begin if
you're the governor of a state or the
mayor of a city you got to deal with
reality you know it's like
it's like saying well i don't know that
i want to pick up the snow you got to
pick up the snow
yeah i read this heartbreaking twitter
thread by this nurse i want to say
in el paso i was somewhere in texas and
she she couldn't take it anymore
she she quit at least for now and on her
last day
she told a coronavirus patient who
didn't
who she didn't think was going to make
it he still didn't believe it was true
and then until they wheeled him out and
and he saw all the people in the icus
and then
he changed his mind um
a thousand people one in a thousand
people in north dakota thereabouts have
now died
of covet they have a mass mandate now
not in south dakota not in montana but
the governor there mark gordon says he
may
have to step in i think they they wanted
people to take responsibility but a lot
of people just aren't
well i mean look why is this spreading
it's not
according to the experts that i've
talked to it's not because the disease
has gotten worse
uh it's because we're not taking the
steps and obviously
one of the steps was to stay outside and
that's become much harder to do
uh as we get cold weather uh you know
it's not like winter
or late fall early winter is is
unforeseeable
uh but had we
taken you know the three w's wear a mask
uh
i forget with it stay socially distance
wash your hands
uh you you you know you you do
everything you can and do a lot
to down play the you know the the the
likelihood to mitigate the risk of this
disease
and in too many states we i understand
it people have gotten tired of it it's
going on
so long but people uh have gotten
sloppy i've gotten lazy and uh
as as a result you know we were seeing
this
huge fight i mean remember back in april
when everybody thought oh my god we're
getting 35 000 cases a day i remember
when i interviewed the president
at the white house in july and we had 70
000 cases a day which was doubled to 35
000.
now we've got 180 000 more than doubled
to 75 000.
you know it's it's been this this this
mountain of the
rise and then a fall and then a bigger
rise and a fall and then now we're in
the steepest rise yet and and you know
this these numbers are unimaginable
uh 100 we're getting close to 200
000 cases a day and we're over 250 000
deaths so far
from this disease and the search
unfortunately happens to be hitting with
thanksgiving coming up and then
christmas coming up and it's going to be
a hard for a lot of families to not keep
up their traditions and
you know what you tell yourself well i
can't get sick from uncle dave that's
uncle dave
it'll be fine so i i mean i assume the
numbers are just going to keep getting
worse and worse before
early january yeah i'm going to tell
your listeners a story
frankly about me and i'm just i'm just
going to put it out there i
have not seen uh one of my children my
eldest son
and his wife and my three grandchildren
since february and they uh have a place
they live in new york they have a house
out uh
on long island and i was gonna go up for
thanksgiving
and see them and you know my wife and i
were gonna drive up we're gonna drive
straight through not stop anywhere
uh go up there and you know last week
i decided i had to pull the plug on it i
i hate that
you know i really want to see my three
grandchildren but i think it's
irresponsible
to them i think it's irresponsible to us
uh and i you know all i'm saying is
i you know i have decided that that's
you'd
you know rather be safe than sorry and
you know we we have spent eight or nine
months those of us who haven't gotten
sick
protecting ourselves and doing the right
thing particularly now with these
vaccines around the corner and
therapeutics getting better
it's the last time we should let down
our guard uh
speaking of the vaccines president-elect
biden says he wants coordination on all
this
including vaccine distribution um
it seems to me that you should no matter
if you're gonna fight this or not in
court the president it seems to me you
should be able to say on parallel tracks
look we'll cooperate at least on
coronavirus and matters of national
security you don't have to be certified
to do that what's the what's the white
house argument against it
the white house argument is obviously it
looks like the president is
conceding i couldn't agree with you more
uh chris i i just think
uh you know the stakes are so high and
i've talked to a number of people
some inside the trump administration who
say there is going to be a real price
if there is you know is no concession no
transition
uh and and instead of hitting the ground
running on january 20th president-elect
biden
you know hits the ground going from a
standing start
and i agree with you what's the possible
damage
to letting them know what your plans are
what your distribution plans are what
your mitigation plans are
and frankly i mean it's the former vice
president it's it's uh
uh kamala harris is getting intel
briefings anyway
to giving them national security
information the worst thing that happens
is you've wasted the time of the
briefers to give them this information
the
the good news is that if he does end up
as the president-elect
he's in better shape to to handle these
these things i don't understand
i mean i understand it from a narrow
political
messaging purpose you don't want to give
them the information or try
because it makes it harder to claim that
they've stolen the election from you
but it seems to me that possible cost
versus the
enormous benefit to just giving the
briefings that's all
just give the briefings don't concede uh
all it does is help the country yeah you
don't have to have mobile for lunch i
mean
even if you do it off-site if you want
to make it look better or
i mean the vaccine news is remarkable
and that the trials
have gone better than anybody's wildest
dreams and i hope the distribution goes
as well uh
hhs secretary alex azar health and human
services told me
that the plan is in place to get it to
states and go from there have you spoken
with anybody about it
um well yeah i mean i that that there is
a plan
in place but all i know is and and you
know i talked last week on fox news
sunday said
dr vivek murthy former surgeon general
he's part of the
covid advisory council for for
president-elect biden and he says we
need this information it's gonna you
know it'll
it'll save lives if we have this
information i agree with you
you know operation workspeed and i'll
give all credit to president trump on
that because
you know this and i think the key there
was a private public partnership it
wasn't just the government
that was you know using the government
with seed money more than seed money
uh you know to these companies like
pfizer and moderna
to to get going on all this and to even
start paying for millions of doses when
you didn't even know whether the dang
thing was going to work but you know it
looks like it's going to work and
you're going to be very happy you had
all those doses but
again i don't understand why for the
good of the country you don't
try to create if i repeat not when
if there's a transition that it's as
seamless and smooth and effective as
possible
polls show that a majority of republican
voters are at least close to a majority
depending on the poll
do have doubts about the legitimacy of
the election and no matter what the
evidence ends up showing
some people are going to say for four
years or eight years joe biden
was elected it wasn't elected that it's
illegitimate now is this just going to
be forever with everything with every
national emergency every election
is just going to be called by fake news
by enough people in charge that a lot of
people buy into that
well you know i i i would hate to think
so but you begin to
wonder if that might not be the case and
i i hear
you know the trump supporters who say
well don't tell me about
delegitimizing a president because
democrats spent
four years with the russia investigation
and
and all of that trying to delegitimize
donald trump i hear that and there's a
cost
to that and there certainly was a cost
in terms of the legitimacy and the
credibility
and uh of donald trump in a lot of
americans minds so
so i i understand that but that doesn't
make what's happening now
any writer and look any of
in in our history with these margins
and with the lack of of evident proof of
uh you know a fraud or or you know some
kind of miscounting
a president the the the the president
would have conceded or the
failing candidate losing candidate would
have conceded i'm not even saying that
he has to concede but
but i think to to have these
statements about fraud and the president
saying that we were robbed and this
you know this election was illegitimate
and he won
you know that's gonna that's there's a
price there and it's one thing to say i
want to contest it and
you know seek all my legal remedies it's
another thing to claim
that that he won the election and if he
loses it was stolen from him
because let's just assume and i think
it's the
far more likely outcome that joe biden
takes the oath of office on january 20th
there will be a price to his ability to
to lead the country just as there was
with with the democrats and russia and
all of that with
trump and it's a very bad path to go
through and to the degree that
this becomes commonplace in our country
it weakens our democracy
chris wallace host to fox news sunday
enjoy uh whatever thanksgiving
you do have i'll probably talk yeah it's
just it's just my wife lorraine and me
staring at a a your log on a tv and it's
not even christmas
that sounds about what i'm good i'm
seriously folks just be safe
just really you know forget the moment
i know everybody wants to be together
and i know how lonely we've been
but this you can't give up now we're so
close to the finish line
thanks chris thank you chris
[Music]
it's the perino and stir walt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris steierwell
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
we may be in a global pandemic but the
north american aerospace defense command
is still going to be keeping an
eye on santa on christmas eve norad says
there will be a few changes though
usually 150 to 160 volunteers gather in
a big conference room at peterson air
force base in colorado springs
and answer calls from thousands of
excited children who want to know where
santa
is this year due to social distancing
that number has been drastically reduced
so some callers won't be able to get
through they will still be able to see
santa's route at
noradsanta.org as well as on social
media and santa tracking apps coming
soon to the google play and
apple app stores tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
tammy bruce
what's on your mind what kind of people
have to be hectored into issuing a weak
petulant sentence about violence exactly
upon their political opposition
the biden harris team and democratic
leadership that's who
saturday november 14th was a day when
tens of thousands of president trump
supporters
peacefully completely not mostly
demonstrated at the maga march in
washington d.c
marxist black lives matter and antifa
were there too
but were outnumbered when the pro-trump
crowd began to disperse those usual
suspects
proceeded to harass threaten and exact
violence against those
who were simply showing support for the
president this was not a new
scene supporters of president trump have
faced verbal
emotional and physical assaults
throughout his presidency
in addition to attempts by media to
destroy the lives of others
like covington kid nick sandman whether
it be adults getting screamed at in
restaurants
being attacked for their support of the
president to children being assaulted by
adults and other children
for wearing trump 2020 hats democratic
political violence has become
commonplace
ironically the biden harris campaign
laughably made calls for unity
a cornerstone of their campaign as they
pledged to quote
heal the soul of the nation this as
video from the maga march of
blm antifa and black box anarchist
assaults on families
older americans and trump supporters in
general went viral on social media
for 48 hours not a peep was heard from
the biden harris campaign
about supporters of the president being
physically attacked that saturday
afternoon
maybe they were too busy crafting more
media blurbs about unity
only after being criticized by
commenters on television
and throughout social media did joe
biden campaign office
finally respond sort of responding to a
fox news request for a statement
mr biden's spokesman issued this terse
and petulant statement quote
president-elect biden continues to
denounce all acts of violence
likewise he also condemns the repugnant
displays of white supremacy
that were made in washington dc this
weekend
who says something that vague when two
specific groups have been terrorizing
americans for the entire year
in the name of the politically liberal
leftist agenda
why is it so difficult for them to
simply repudiate the political violence
those two specific groups are unleashing
nationwide
and why the effort to deflect by
mentioning what was reported as a sign
carried by someone in a crowd of tens of
thousands
placards with offensive statements
should be condemned
but why use it to distract from physical
violence against the innocent
or is the biden team implying trump
supporters are the type who deserve to
be attacked
even during the general election season
neither former vice president biden nor
senator harris
used their considerable influence to
demand an end to this abject violence
terrorizing innocent citizens only when
polls come out indicating
that voters across the country were
appalled and concerned about safety
and the unfolding riots and violence
would affect their vote
did mr biden emerge from his basement
and someone on his team bothered to draw
up a generic statement condemning once
again all violence
the issue is not condemning violence in
general most people do
the issue is confronting democratic
leadership
and the fact that it includes the biden
harris team
that they must condemn political
violence by these specific groups
that is applied against those who are
perceived as political enemies
it's telling that they find that too
high
a mountain of all the things americans
are learning through the democratic
party's hypocrisy
and corey remarks about political
violence is when the democrats
patronizingly speak of unity what they
really mean
is submission
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes